Speaker 1: Welcome everybody, I want to start
today off and start the week off with something
we really haven't done in about in about six
weeks, which is just kind of go over what's
going on with COVID because things have changed
pretty dramatically over the last six weeks.
We've not done the weekly COVID updates that
at one point we were doing. My thought was
first of all, with so much else going on.
There's no shortage of things to talk about,
but also let's really give this Omicron wave four
to six weeks to burn through and see where we are
once we close in on mid-February. And for the most
part, in the United States, things are looking so
much better that there are now what I would call
serious discussions about moving into the endemic
phase. Whereas before there was a lot of kind of
hear no evil, see, no evil. Let's just go back to
pretending everything is normal. Things are not
normal now, but the discussions about next steps
make a lot more sense. And as I've said before,
we before we look at the numbers, if there is not.
A more deadly new variant. There is sort of
nothing else to wait for before we figure
out what will what will things be like with
this as an endemic thing? Now endemic doesn't
necessarily mean no risk, and to many people, it
still means a risk. But the question is sort of,
if not now when? Because if we are moving into an
endemic phase with no really serious new variant
for one year, two years, three years, what are we
going to do over those one, two or three years? If
not now? What would be different in two years if
the situation remains sort of as it is now now?
One caveat to that is even though cases are
dropping dramatically, as I will soon show you,
it's going to take some time for the
hospitals to empty out. We are still seeing
hospitals quite full right now because
of the waves peak now many weeks ago,
and it will take some time for that to abate,
assuming there's no new, really contagious and
or deadly variant. But let's look at where we
are right now. If you look at the United States,
daily cases are now down from an insane peak
of 800000 cases a day, all the way down to
two hundred and thirty nine thousand now. That's
still a lot. It puts a sort of at the Delta Peak,
but with a variant with significantly lower rate
of hospitalization rate. Remember, that's down
about through almost almost three quarters. You
look at some individual states, you look at New
York. New York peaked at 75000 cases a day and
is down to about 8000, you know, almost a 90
90 percent reduction. You look at Massachusetts.
Massachusetts peaked at about 24000 cases a day,
down all the way down to 3000. OK, that's a
massive, massive reduction. Even places like Texas
seeing a reduction only about 50 percent, but
still going in the downward direction. And then
when you look globally, globally, the decline
is earlier. We are earlier in the decline.
We had gotten to 3.3 million global cases a day
now down to 2.7 million. So there are parts of
the world that are nowhere near doing well, as we
would say. And we will talk about some of those
in a moment. But the important thing for our
purposes is that we are seeing countries, states,
school districts start to talk about what are the
next steps now in terms of vaccinating kids under
five. There's the hope. I mean, I think the most
optimistic prediction is by March that may start.
It's plausible. It's not going to be March
and it could be April, maybe or maybe even
May. But you are starting to see a lot of
places make decisions about travel. For example,
Australia, which has been one of the tightest
strictest places since the start of the pandemic,
will be reopening borders to international
travel, as reported by the BBC.
That's from this morning. So Australia starting
to open. There are a number of additional European
countries that are moving towards what we might
call an exit from the pandemic. Italy, Switzerland
and Finland are going to be easing restrictions
and guidelines. Germany and Belgium so far
are not. But many other countries, Denmark and
others are going back to normal, as we might say.
Still, of course, with the caveat that there
are going to be people who are going to continue
doing whatever they've been doing.
And one of the interesting things
that we've talked about before is there's this
discussion of when can we treat this like flu?
One answer to make it an empirical answer and
not an emotional answer. One answer would be
when the death rate matches that of flu, that that
would be something to look at. It is hypothesized
that the AMA coren overall death rate is about 0.2
percent. Flu is zero point one five. So we're not
there yet, but it's going in that direction. One
additional caveat to that is the death rate for
the vaccinated is significantly lower than the
zero point two percent. The death rate for the
unvaccinated is significantly higher. So what you
can safely. The framework that you can accurately
assess for yourself does depend significantly
on whether you are or aren't vaccinated. But
one of those questions is well, when the death
rate becomes that of the flu, it would make sense
to go back to normal, right? Well, no. The reality
is that these two years have exposed for a lot
of people. I wasn't as safe as I thought during
flu season, and there are absolutely people who
used to not take any precautions when flu
was rampant during flu season. But even.
If and when COVID risk goes back down to match
flu, it will still feel more dangerous and that
people will be more aware of that risk and they
may continue to take precautions. And of course,
everybody should do exactly what makes sense
for them. In conversation with doctors and
based on their risk assessment. But that's the
conversation that's happening. South Korea,
as reported by the Korea Herald, pushes to treat
COVID 19 like flu. They have lots of cases,
but low severity, relatively low hospitalizations
relative quite quite a low death rate. So that's
the South Korean perspective. In New Jersey, the
governor will be ending the school mask mandate
next month in March, and there are many
municipalities I saw some in. And by the way,
there are places that never did anything. It's
like, I'm not even talking or thinking about
those I'm talking about. Places that did stuff
are now having conversations. There are some
municipalities in Massachusetts that are moving
away from the masks. Some in New York. A number of
different places. Caveat things are still not good
in a lot of places. Russia has hit a new record.
They currently have 10 times more cases than a
month ago. To the extent that we can believe the
Russian data, it is now 10 times higher cases
than a month ago. That's not good for them.
Hong Kong is bracing for more curbs or guidelines
mandates as cases are doubling every three days.
Very complicated situation in Hong Kong, China
is locking down Bays City on the Vietnam border
as cases are continuing to go up. Still low
numbers. And of course, China has taken a sort of
at least officially a zero COVID approach now,
whether that's zero COVID or zero COVID reporting.
You know, there's debate about that, but there are
significant lockdowns happening there as well. So
what can we do? Well, I think again, the question
is reminder we've been here before. What is
different now? The difference is there is more
support for the discussion now about moving into
the endemic phase in terms of public opinion
than there ever was before. But there's also
more support from medical experts. We spoke
to Vincent Racaniello two weeks ago. We've
read the opinions of many other public health
experts and if things change, it will require
a different approach. But if we are going in this
direction, then there is this question of what are
the milestones we are waiting for? And there are
people who are going to keep themselves in a sort
of purgatory for a very long time. That's the
reality. And every individual has to balance.
You know, their their risk tolerance, their health
situation and the mental health impact that is
that is undeniable. I mean, you know, the right is
not wrong when they say there is a mental health
impact of doing this. It's a question of when does
the balance shift? And the answer is different for
everybody. So we're going to continue
monitoring all of these decisions
and seeing if the down trend continues, which
if it does within another two weeks, we could
we could be 95 to 97 percent down in terms
of daily cases. And when you have that,
combined with the effectiveness of vaccines at
preventing death, you really have a dramatically
different situation to consider in terms
of what every individual wants to be doing.